حظرت روسيا السفر من المملكة المتحدة ،
الهند ،
كندا ، هناك قلق بشأن هذا
النوع الجديد من فيروس كورونا الذي يبدو
أنه ينتشر خارج نطاق السيطرة
في المملكة المتحدة.
أنا
حول هذا الموضوع المهم ، لقد أجريت
مناقشة مستفيضة مع الدكتور ريدفيلد
وكبار مسؤوليه الليلة الماضية
وهذا ما نعرفه أن البديل
الذي تتم مناقشته قد تم تحديده لأول مرة
في سبتمبر ، لذا فهو ليس
شيئًا نشأ في الأسبوع
الماضي لقد أصبح  مثير للقلق لأنه
أصبح البديل السائد في المملكة المتحدة
أه الاستدلال هو أنه
لأنه المتغير السائد فقد يكون أكثر قابلية
للانتقال وقد يكون
هذا صحيحًا لم يتم إثباته ولكن قد يكون
صحيحًا دعني أخبرك بما يوجد  لا يوجد
دليل على
عدم وجود سبب للاعتقاد بأنه ليس
أكثر فتكًا
أو أكثر خطورة من الفيروس التاجي العادي ،
ولا يوجد دليل يشير إلى عدم
وجود نية  يا بني أن نصدق أنه لا يوجد
دليل يشير إلى عدم وجود سبب للاعتقاد
بأنه سيتهرب من لقاحاتنا التي
نتذكرها الآن
أن لقاحاتنا تطور أجسامًا مضادة
ضد
أجزاء متعددة من هذا البروتين المرتفع وليس فقط
واحدًا متحورًا
لذلك نحن  متشجع جدًا بشأن ذلك
ولكن بالطبع لدينا الكثير من العمل
لفهم هذا الأمر
بشكل كامل